good morning believe nation today's
message is you are valuable over to you
Nick voyage amigo every single human
being has value and my value is not
determined on how I look or what job I
have or where I'm from where I was born
how much money all that stuff is nothing
so many teenagers you know tease each
other for how we look and I tell the
teenagers do you think that I'm cool
enough to be your friend they're like
yeah of course so but I have no arms no
legs they said doesn't matter said
really so it doesn't matter that I have
no arms no legs I said no it doesn't
matter I said then actually if it
doesn't matter then why do we kill each
other with our words if it actually
doesn't matter why do we look ourselves
in the mirror and see ugly instead of
valuable I really love this message and
I think it's at the core of what I want
to do with my life and when I do with
this channel is helping people believe
in themselves right a lot of people
don't believe that they have value that
they can create something that is of
value and they may have been told their
entire life that you know you can't do
that you know you can't chase that dream
what gives you the right or the audacity
to quote and try to do that you didn't
go to school for that you know your
parents can't give you the money to go
and do that whatever it whatever is the
reason and a lot of people even worse
tell themselves that right like you are
your own worst critic you tell
yourselves all the reasons why you won't
be able to achieve whatever goal why you
won't be able to accomplish that why you
can't make that connection why you can't
be a successful entrepreneur why you
can't you know have that kind of life we
tell ourselves all these stories and
have these limiting person believes as
to why we can't break through and that's
why I started this channel you know
started for me like every major
breakthrough I've made in my life has
come from smashing a living in personal
belief where I realized I actually can
do that why didn't think I'm so long to
try and then also trying to help others
through the same process right I think
if you guys have been
loyal longtime viewers you will help you
will have changed like if you watch one
of these videos every day you will
change you can't help but change your
environment is changing you cannot help
but get a little bit of that wisdom from
these famous entrepreneurs and have it
rub off on you in some way giving you
more confidence giving you more sense of
value giving you a more belief in
yourself and what you're doing and for
those of you who might be newer you know
welcome aboard you're in for a fun ride
I think it's super important that you
believe in yourself and that you find
value in yourself and what you can do
stop hanging around the little man stop
hanging around the people who don't
build you up and just tear you down and
just find all the reasons why you can't
be successful like kick those people out
of your life and do your best to quiet
that voice inside your head that little
man voice that says you can't do it and
for me at least the more i found myself
with greatness the more I surround
myself with people who are doing amazing
things the more I look at them and
absorb their wisdom and just hang around
them even virtually even look through
the computer through the videos through
what's on the wall the more I surround
myself with that the more confidence and
courage and belief i have in the value
that i can provide to encourage me to go
and do the best that I can do and become
the best version of Evan Carmichael that
I can be so the question they today is
I'm curious what you do to show yourself
that you are valuable whether your
habits your routine your environment
what is it that you show yourself that I
can do more that I can contribute more
than I'm doing right now and that belief
in yourself what do you do what's the
process you go through shared in
comments below I'm curious to find out
but I think it also helped a lot of the
other people watching who may be
struggling as to how they can find their
own body so please share it up below I
also want to give a quick shadow to an
erotic manga thank you so much for
buying my book it means a lot to me for
you guys watching for your chains at a
shadow in your future video make sure
you pick up a copy of the book and email
in the receipt thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events vesa
away
more expresso keep me go